nos piden graficar la función f x igual
a menos 3 x al cuadrado más 8 lo que
vamos a hacer es tomar algunos valores
de x ver cuando vale f x poner esos
puntos en una gráfica y después pues más
o menos extrapolar osea conectar los
puntos para ver cómo se vería la gráfica
en general pero antes de hacer esto me
gustaría que pensáramos un poquito en
cómo se va a ver la gráfica o sea qué
tipo de gráficas serán si tenemos menos
3x al cuadrado más 8 será una línea una
parábola un círculo o algo así como muy
extraño bueno resulta que va a quedar
una parábola y eso tiene que ver con que
esto es un polinomio de grado 2 un
polinomio cuadrática vale bueno pero hay
dos tipos de parábolas las parábolas
pueden abrir hacia abajo ser más o menos
como una invertida o pueden abrir hacia
arriba ser como una y una
un normal
bueno qué tipo de parábola será pues
como aquí tenemos un -3 que es un
coeficiente principal negativo resulta
que la parábola va a abrir hacia abajo
bueno entonces la intuición nos dice que
vamos a obtener una parábola que abre
hacia abajo vamos a ver si sí es cierto
para esto déjame pintar aquí el eje x el
eje x es este el horizontal vamos a
poner aquí el eje x vamos a poner acá el
eje i
el eje y vamos a ver cuánto vale esta
función en algunos valores estos valores
los voy a poner en una tabla por acá
entonces aquí tenemos este una tabla
donde aquí vamos a poner los valores de
x y acá los de g
recuerda que ya va a estar dada por efe
de x bueno y esos valores que vamos a
poner digo tiene que ser una muestra del
dominio y el dominio son todos los
reales pero no nos conviene que sean muy
grandes porque si no pues va a ser muy
complicado evaluar la función ahí así
que déjame poner que los valores en los
cuales vamos a evaluar la función f son
menos 2
- 1
0 1 y 2 va antes de poner la escala en
déjame llenar la tabla para que sepamos
más o menos hasta dónde tengo que llegar
va bueno entonces déjame empezar con x
igual a menos 2 si x es igual a menos 2
cuanto vale ya fx y fx está dada por
esta expresión de acá entonces nos
quedaría menos 3 x menos 2 al cuadrado
más 8 vale cuántos esto de acá esto es
menos 3 x menos 2 al cuadrado menos 2 al
cuadrado es 4 menos tres por cuatro es
menos 12 y sea menos 12 le sumamos 8 nos
quedan menos 4 muy bien voy a seguir
llenando la tabla
voy a poner aquí al menos 1 que nos
quedaría nos quedaría menos 3 x menos 1
al cuadrado más 8 menos 1 al cuadrado es
uno menos 3 por 1 es menos 3 entonces
este de aquí sería igual
muy bien déjame pasar al color morado
para ver x igual a cero entonces si x es
igual a cero efe de x 3 - 3 x 0 8 menos
3 bueno x 0 al cuadrado más 8 esto de
aquí es un cero aquí nos queda igual a 8
muy bien déjame continuar con otros dos
valores voy a poner aquí el 1 nos
quedaría menos 3 por 1 al cuadrado más
81 al cuadrado es 1
menos tres por uno es menos tres aquí
nos queda igual a cinco mira cómo que ya
empieza a ser simétrico alrededor del
cero verdad y finalmente finalmente
déjame ponerle x igualados si x es igual
a 2 nos queda menos 3 por 2 al cuadrado
más 8 y esta cuenta ya la habíamos hecho
es la misma que acá porque 2 al cuadrado
es lo mismo que menos 2 al cuadrado vaya
nos queda menos 3 por 4 que es menos 12
más 8 que es menos 4 menos 4 muy bien ya
teniendo los valores en que ahora sí
podemos dar una escala adecuada en el
eje y para que la gráfica nos quede
bonita entonces pues tenemos que llegar
hasta 8 en los positivos y hasta menos 4
en los negativos así que nos conviene
poner el 8 más o menos por acá está el 8
entonces el 4 estaría a esta altura y el
menos cuatro sería el reflejado del 4
con respecto al cero o sea quedaría más
o menos como por acá más o menos como
por acá menos 4 sale entonces si éste es
8 este de acá 6
este de acá es 2 este ya que es el 0 lo
voy a poner aquí por aquí tenemos 135
y 7 por acá menos 2 - 1 3 vale bueno
ahora sí ya teniendo los ejes
etiquetados y con la escala adecuada
vamos a pasar cada uno de estos puntos
aquí al plano entonces el primero es el
punto menos dos menos 4 - 2 menos cuatro
es este punto de acá muy bien luego
tenemos el menos 15 tenemos el menos 1,5
sería este punto de por acá vale por
aquí este el 5 entonces este es el
déjame déjame ponerle sus coordenadas al
menos 15 este de acá es el menos dos
menos cuatro coma menos cuatro muy bien
luego tenemos el 0.8 el 0,8 que queda
por acá
este es el 0,8 eso parece un 6 deja de
ponerle más bonito el cero
muy bien este es el punto morado vamos
al punto azul el punto azul está en 1515
y recuerda todos estos puntos que estoy
pintando el hecho de que los esté
pintando es que quiere decir que están
en la gráfica de la función de hecho por
eso los estoy pintando para hacerme una
idea de cómo se ve 1,5
finalmente déjame poner este de acá el 2
menos 4 que sería este punto de por aquí
más o menos vale el 2 menos 4 y ahora sí
ya que tenemos estos 5 puntos pues
podemos más o menos hacernos una idea de
cómo se ve la gráfica de la función o
sea nos ayudan a pues ver más o menos
cómo está la cosa verdad entonces
necesitamos una curva que una a estos
cinco déjame tomar el color blanco
para más o menos trazar lo que nos queda
entonces nos queda más o menos una curva
de este estilo viene por acá llega a
este punto
luego se empieza a aplanar
y
y después es simétrica y es trabajar así
pasa por este punto y luego tiene que
bajar un poco más rápido para alcanzar
ese de allá
más o menos algo de este estilo muy bien
entonces esto está padre verdad esto
coincide con nuestra intuición aquí ya
tenemos la gráfica de la función que de
hecho continúa continúa y lo importante
es que esta línea no sólo tiene los
cinco puntos muestra que pusimos sino
que además tiene todos los puntos que
están en el dominio de la función o sea
tiene todos los puntos correspondientes
a la gráfica vale muy bien entonces nos
queda esta cosa de acá es una parábola
eso está fantástico porque coincide con
la intuición que habíamos agarrado desde
aquí